>> My name is Catalina Ruiz-Healy. I'm the
creator of Catalista for Android, which is
an application that helps you find local and
timely volunteer opportunities from your phone,
and you can rate them, and once you've done
your good deed, you can share it with the
world.
>> MCFADDEN: My name is Wayne McFadden. And
I'm with Redroid Software and I assisted with
the development of the new product.
>> RUIZ-HEALY: Android is a great platform
for an early-stage developer. The partner
that I co-founded the company with is the
Java developer and we're very excited about
experimenting and entering quickly on the
platform. We can--we could release to the
market easily and make changes as we got customer
feedback. And we like working with Google.
It's an exciting company. And, Wayne, would
you add to that?
>> MCFADDEN: Android provides a lot of the
features and functionality that our team wanted
from--everything from mapping of events to
the opportunities to work with charities to
being able to integrate with back-end applications
such as Google Calendar--we'll talk a little
about it later--just a whole wealth of features
that can be used that really fit well with
where the product team wanted to take the
product.
>> So, can you give us a little more detail
about your application?
>> RUIZ-HEALY: Sure. So, the detail about
the application is that based on your physical
location, the GPS on your phone helps you
find volunteer opportunities in your area.
You can search for them based on whether you're
interested in doing something over the weekend
or if you're interested in doing a beach cleanup.
You can save them to My Calista, which tracks
sort of what you're interested in. You can
schedule that event on your Google Calendar.
You can sign up with the provider directly.
You can call the organization. And then once
you've done it, then you can actually talk
about what you've been able do. And so you're
able to say that I've walked 30 dogs for two
hours and I've rated my experience as a five-star,
and that then is broadcast over different
social media. There's also a very cool Cupcake
feature which is the Live Folder feature,
which is you can long-press on your screen
and you can have two options--one, is you
get a live feed from the Catalista database,
but you can also see those events that you
have actually saved and that you're tracking.
And if you click on one of those opportunities,
you actually re-launch the application and
you can go ahead and call or schedule and,
again, rate your experience.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MCFADDEN: Well, as a Java developer, the--you
rely on the Eclipse. I used that on projects
before, and just being able to plug and play
the Android development environment right
into that is great. So, it has all the wealth
of resources that come with Eclipse like the
[INDISTINCT] tools and things like that. We
found that the upgrade process from the 1.0
version of the application to the 1.5 app
version was really well done. I've worked
on many projects where when you're trying
to upgrade from one version of the underlying
software to the others is just a disaster.
And this went totally smooth, so, that was
pretty cool. The feature that I think I had
most fun developing was the integration with
Google Calendar on the web where many people
use--utilize Google Calendar for scheduling
and things like that--we were able to integrate
our application with the web version of the
Google Calendar by passing data back to it.
So, what that means is someone can find an
event that they want to attend, to volunteer
somewhere. Click a button and then to have
it appear in your--their web version of the
Google Calendar as a reminder. That was a
lot of fun doing it.
>> RUIZ-HEALY: I would add from a product
development perspective. I think getting feedback
from users right away was really important,
that you--we don't have to wait two weeks
to get approval from the market and that we
can iterate as quickly as we can, and we can
improve on the product as quickly as we can
do it. So, that's really, really valuable.
>> And what features [INDISTINCT]?
>> I'd like to see notifications be easier,
so, a way for us to really--I mean, the vision
would be that you're walking down the street
next to a food bank and that your phone can
pick up that you're next to this food bank
and let you know that there's a way for you
to help out tomorrow or next week, and really
encourage people to make a difference in their
community and schedule that and then show
up and make a difference.
>> MCFADDEN: I think, like I said, with the
upgrade process, it was relatively smooth.
And that goes along with the documentation,
too. I think they took great strides in improving
the documentation [INDISTINCT] different versions,
which is great, because as a developer you
obviously need that. All in all, I think the
project in general, despite the fact that
I think with the Live Folders, which is brand
new 1.5, and the calendar integration, which
is brand new 215, and the sophistication of
the mapping where you can get a hundred events
or so on, it will appear on the map. All in
all, it went really well. So, like I said
before, it was fun.
>> Well, thanks for talking to us. I hope
you enjoy [INDISTINCT].
>> RUIZ-HEALY: Thanks.
>> MCFADDEN: Thank you.